there's one thing the GOP candidates
could all agree on Joe Biden has
completely bungled the Border
Republicans offering up their solutions
to fix it
I'm not going to send troops to Ukraine
but I am going to send them to our
Southern border when these drug pushers
are bringing fentanyl across the border
that's going to be the last thing they
do we're going to use force and we're
going to leave them stone cold I think
that this is disastrous that we are
protecting against an invasion across
somebody else's border when we should
use those same military resources to
prevent across the invasion of our own
Southern border and we will partner with
the Mexican military and we will hunt
down and destroy the cartels that are
claiming lives in the United States that
would be lethal Force used by the border
patrol law enforcement as needed to
protect the Border absolutely I will
make that border wall
complete oh man powerful stuff there
Jesse it sounds like another idea that
sprung from this table bombed the
cartels however you have some insight
into these cartel Stones you've been
following them for years uh they're not
just about drugs in human trafficking I
mean they're like becoming big business
like we don't deal with this now they're
going to be dealing with us later true
and on our turf yeah I didn't understand
the solution I didn't get any specifics
yes we have to get tough on the border
yes Trump said that we have to designate
cartels Terror organizations and then
that can kind of Ratchet up the CIA or
paramilitary operations but what does
that look like they're just kind of
following what fox has said or following
what Trump has said what does it mean
when you're going to have border patrol
agents shooting coyotes in Texas what is
what do you mean by that yeah we're just
going to have everybody shooting anybody
that comes across the border how do you
know they're a coyote and they say you
want to stop fentanyl coming in from
China well how
how are they going to make China stop
shipping it how are they going to
partner with the Mexican military all of
a sudden we're partnering with the
Mexican military all of a sudden how are
we going to do that and you trust the
Mexican military Mexican military is
getting outgunned by the cartels does
the Mexican military want to partner
with us because they're on the take from
the cartels
and it wasn't just the Border we didn't
hear specifics on how they're going to
reduce inflation are you going to throw
Powell out the door
what are you going to do to make people
earn more money we didn't hear a lot of
specifics last night and like a father
I'm disappointed wow judge what about
this whole point about China it's like
is that are we going to bomb China too I
mean you know now you know the one thing
that I heard that I thought was
interesting was Santa saying he would
send in Special Forces into Mexico
um look we have an idea where the drugs
are coming from obviously and where how
they're getting into the United States
we've I mean we're smart enough to deal
with that we deal with it in other
countries we certainly should be able to
deal with it on our own border
um and I think that DeSantis
um unlike most of the people on the
stage has actually dealt with not the
Border per se but the consequences where
he ends up sending the immigrants to
other states mentioned that last night
he never mentioned he sent him to the
vineyard oh well I I mentioned a forum
he asked me to mention that
um but but I think that the important
thing is that we that this past month in
July the the influx is up 30 percent so
everyone said oh you know after title 42
is is down then you know everything is
called going down we had 130 000 people
coming in in July it's got to stop why
is it easier to come here illegally than
legally we got to make it easier to come
here legally than illegally and I think
that the auctioning off the border wall
that Trump left is an insult to the
American people I I remember being at
the border right after Trump left office
and I remember seeing all this metal and
steel and saying we're security nobody's
watching this and now Biden is selling
it just to make sure if a republican
can't comes in that they can't rebuild
the walls so I really think that uh the
fact that 80 percent of Americans
approve of construction of a border wall
if you nurse to desantis's benefit
so Jessica we do take out terrorists in
other countries and it's pretty fair to
say somebody who who brings drugs in
that kill 100 000 people is a terrorist
so what's different
well I think when we kill terrorists in
other countries most of the time they
have hostile governments that we're not
working with the Mexicans are obviously
an incredibly strong Ally of ours and
the supposition would be that there
could be some conversation about shared
military resources or you know cartel
kings that it would benefit them and
benefit us to take them out so I don't
think this idea of we're just going to
show up and start using deadly force
which is what DeSantis has been talking
about for the last week and then
everyone echoed him last night is really
feasible
um I will say I largely agreed with what
Jesse said it's never happened before
but it happened today he sounded very
Democratic no he found it very which is
important to acknowledge that he sounded
like he thought that Donald Trump was
the one who had the ideas about this and
that's how majority it seems that the
Republican base feels that way I will
say though on the fentanyl issue and no
one brought this up talking about we got
to stop the fentanyl that's why we're
going after the cartels in China Etc the
majority of fentanyl is trafficking into
this country by Americans so what are
you going to do about that are you going
to be shooting Americans at the border
that's how this is going to work does it
come through the Border or is it coming
through you mean ports of Entry yeah
yeah full of Fentanyl what are you going
to do how do they know that though
because because then they come in and
that's how we know how much we're
teasing but we don't get any of the
stuff that comes across undetected right
so we don't know we do we get both Dana
you know yeah it's a we it's it's
actually kind of the point that I was
going to make about terrorists so we
know how much we catch in terms of the
border patrol pulls over a car wow
there's all this fentanyl in it they
record it so you know that you don't
know what you're not catching we also
don't know how many people have come in
the country that you don't catch what do
they call those there's a the common
denominator is missing the other thing
is I thought that the candidates last
night missed an opportunity to hit back
at Biden so 146
people on the terrorism watch list have
come across the border that we know of
that we caught yeah
what 146. amazing and there's why isn't
anyone's hair on fire about that that's
why I missed an opportunity there all
right
my hair is on fire it's amazing thank
you up next former president Donald
Trump on his way to Georgia for his
arrest hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else